so
yesterday
was a pretty surreal moment for me uh
i did a all hands in front of our
company
and
there were 200 people there
so becoming it's kind of interesting i
was thinking becoming a successful
entrepreneur is kind of like getting fat
you just go day to day
you're doing what you're doing
you have to hire someone they do a great
job
more needs pop up you hire more people
and then all of a sudden there's 200
people and uh
what's also interesting along the way is
more and more opportunities and luck and
you realize you have more and more reach
to actually change the world so pretty
crazy
and uh it's super humbling for me to be
in front of 500 hustlers today this is
pretty cool
all right so life before the hustle was
really good
like like many people i totally
squandered my college years
so i i went into college and i want to
say september 1999. so
i skipped class and day traded
i was partying all the time and i played
too much starcraft
i actually got an ultimatum about
starcraft from
someone and chose starcraft so that was
interesting
um
yeah and then so
after college uh
i kind of lost the entrepreneurial bug
to be honest in 2001 uh a market crash
like that can really do it to you i'd
always wanted to be an entrepreneur
going into college but that just didn't
really seem like a reality
so i joined the investment banking
finance hedge fund world
so i was investing in a lot of you know
big technology media and telecom
companies
and then christmas day 2008
so
i felt like i had been winning and
winning and winning in life
you know i had
landed this amazing job at a great hedge
fund
i was one week away from getting that
bonus that was going to change my life
and i was pretty stoked and then
i got fired
so
i mean
i i kind of became a bit of a social
pariah among my friends a lot of people
were getting like yo at this time
and
everything fell apart so it was pretty
horrible
uh so so two things kind of happened in
the next month or two
one was uh
my sister asked me for help finding a
credit card poked around online
was pretty dissatisfied with what was
out there but couldn't quite articulate
what was bugging the crap out of me
about the experience
and then my parents called me
about a month later as well um they said
you know the market has been doing
really horribly our investments aren't
doing well
we're going to hire a financial advisor
and by the way we hired this financial
advisor
he sold us this great product that locks
your rates and gives you like this fixed
payment and
there's a five percent fee and like all
this other crazy stuff so they got
totally screwed
and
the the two problems sound pretty
distinct but over time um i reflected a
bit on this and i realized they're
actually quite similar
there's just information asymmetry
between the people
who are providing the service and the
people who are looking for things to buy
or for great advice
now your friends and family have your
best interests in mind really but they
may not know what's going on i mean
they're not really
financial professionals
and they don't spend all their time
creating excel spreadsheets
and the broker the agent the retail
banker the financial advisor they're
really just doing their job
and the affiliate marketer they're just
doing their job they're feeding their
family they're behave they're not bad
people
now the internet had pretty much changed
this in every single other vertical out
there
but not not yet in finance
so
my first thought was
hey i can solve my sister's problem uh
you know i've been doing excel all my
life i can just suit up shoot some excel
lasers out of my elbows and crank out
this spreadsheet with you know hundreds
of credit cards and i can give her the
objectively correct answer so
this spreadsheet started getting kind of
forwarded around to my friends and
forwarded more and forwarded more and i
said hey this could be a web app i mean
i haven't programmed in 10 years but you
know like let's just put this out on the
internet and
see if it can help people
so i'll talk more about that later
so
another interesting point i mean
consider this my social network had zero
entrepreneurs a bunch of use useless
finance people
and
and and i was launching into this
endeavor starting a company and so why
did i even have a shot
i couldn't raise venture capital
financing if i wanted to i mean where
would i go who would who would give
someone with no programming experience
no startup experience and
you know
like money it just doesn't make any
sense
so
think about this uh
you have a huge advantage uh when you're
kind of launching out
towards a niche so i don't know if you
guys know sites like mr money mustache
or
yeah so so compare mr money mustache to
money magazine
if you have the same values as mr money
mustache you're gonna love everything he
writes money can never compete with mr
money mustache when it comes to that
crud the same with the o'reilly show
versus cnn i mean you kind of or cnn
might be a bad example now but you know
when when you're targeting that niche
where the values of the people who are
your customers are perfectly aligned
with you
you can no one can compete with you so
that was kind of our situation
you're also more nimble than the big
guys
that one's more self-explanatory you
don't have overhead you don't have to
build consensus you can just go
my sister knew a thing or two about
affiliate marketing she had started a
coupon website that had done pretty well
and i thought hey you know at least you
can explain to me how this works and
now i have a mental model of someone
else who has done this that's
had some success so maybe i can do it
too
now finance background is kind of
interesting um that was really more
less about the finance and more because
i could get journalists actually take me
seriously
so that turned out to be really
important over time
and life is an investor the the one
thing um i was actually good at as an
investor was short selling companies so
figuring out which companies were going
to crash and burn
so
i i had met you know thousands of
companies
over the past couple years and
seen like certain patterns that just
weren't quite that good and
i highly recommend
peter thiel's book zero to one a lot of
common principles
you know there's kind of companies that
are going to be mired in brutal
competition their whole lives and
companies who have just these amazing
businesses that are going to get less
and less competitive over time and it's
kind of always one or the other so
figure out which one yours is
here's the first version of nerdwallet
it's a non-technical founders website
um any of you can cut and paste from
stack overflow and put together
something like this in a few weeks
so this is really trying to convert a
spreadsheet
into kind of a kayak for credit cards
uh this is kind of our growth over
the
next six years
the numbers aren't huge by a lot of
standards but these are really high
value intent driven customers shopping
for financial products so these are
really valuable people
so
this is
me coding the first version of the
website
this is a bathroom in uh grenada spain
uh in a hostel so
but i splurged and got my own bathroom
so that was cool
okay so a few things i learned quickly
launched the website
knew it was better than anything else
out there i mean there were so many more
cards listed on the site
it actually told you how to sort the
cards in a logical manner
but no one came and i bet this is a
really common problem among every
entrepreneur
so one thing i quickly realized is
when you're at a sunday barbecue you're
not really triggered to talk about
credit card comparison websites
so i i would definitely keep that in
mind uh you you have to figure out how
to do acquisition
so uh
the second thing i did was say hey
uh you know maybe
journalism or pr is a good megaphone for
what we're trying to do
well
i made the mistake of not talking to
people who had done this before
journalists who receive pitches all the
time or pr people who do this for a
living and just try to go at it on my
own
and that was really inefficient
as you can imagine journalists probably
get thousands of emails a day
from companies just like yours so if you
want to figure out how to get in their
head you have to understand what bugs
them what they need to do their job
and then you'll know how to approach
them
the third thing i realized is seo is a
slog
so
it was really about deciphering hey what
does it take exactly to get to where we
want to go
and
that required figuring out exactly how
much the leaders had of
the main components of search
so i'll talk that i'll talk about that a
bit later but
you know within
five minutes of doing that calculation
realized there was no way we were going
to do this in less than a couple years
last thing that i bet all of you have
run into as well is that paid channels
are prohibitively expensive
so you're basically at auction for
people's attention when you go into a
paid channel like scm
and chances are
our problem was if you want to be more
consumer friendly than anyone else
you're going to be monetizing less than
anyone else
therefore when you're at auction you're
not going to win
so paid was out of the question
so at that point it was about okay i
figured out what the most viable
acquisition channel to build a
sustainable business was at this point
for us it had to be seo
so this is uh
jake and i my co-founder and barbados on
vacation
when we
had a poorly timed life hacker hit and
the entire website went down
because it was cut and pasted from stack
overflow and
hosted on a server that costs seven
dollars a month
so we were trying to fix the site and i
realized
this is when i learned about database
indexing which is kind of funny if any
of you are coders but that's not the
time you want to be learning about
database indexing
okay so 2010 was actually really
demoralizing despite these two
successes so money magazine featured us
as the best credit card website in 2010.
so we saw maybe
i remember we got about seven cents a
visitor so whatever 300 divided by seven
cents is that's how many people can
so uh i thought well what better success
with this press megaphone could we
possibly have
than getting into money magazine i mean
this is a magazine that millions of
people read so
what do we do
i can't get money magazine every day
and even if i did that wouldn't be
nearly enough to sustain a business so
that was highly demoralizing
the second thing was
so jake happens to be
well i won't mention this but we gotta
so jay got us into life hacker
but
it only generated uh five thousand
dollars in revenue so live hacker is
actually much better because it's an
online publication with like millions of
people visiting it so better conversion
rates and traffic but
still you can't get lifehacker every day
okay so what did we do
we realized that seo was this massive
massive fire hose of traffic
and nothing else mattered
so we dropped all of our product
development and just focus on seo
you have no idea how horrible that feels
everything is burning around you
your friends mock your website for being
so ugly
it runs really slowly
but hey your most limited resource is
your time as a founder and you better
let stuff burn if you're going to figure
out how to do the things you need to do
correctly
so
um this was kind of hard work we kind of
like worked worked worked and eventually
we started hiring interns off craigslist
uh
one of who actually turned into a
full-time employee that was super super
instrumental to our success so that's
anisha who ended up
running our credit card business for
three years
okay so 2011 was the first time that we
realized hey this might work
there's really only two things that
matter in seo so
a lot of nerd wallets
people will give me a hard time about
saying the word drivers way too often
but it's all about figuring out the
drivers behind whatever acquisition
channel you're pursuing and just
focusing super super religiously on
those drivers
you want to build your entire business
organization around those drivers if
you're going to get them right
otherwise people are going to start
running off and
trying to help out but not doing the
things that really matter
so in seo it's about quality links and
quality content
what does this mean product doesn't
matter engineering doesn't matter
vc funding doesn't matter
in fact vc funding is detrimental
because no vc is going to wait around
for you to do this the right way
and pr only matters if it builds links
so this is 2011. things are way
different now but this is kind of like
the hustle stage when you're trying to
get off the ground
okay so the other thing that was super
important was realizing
that
google's not a black box use your common
sense
don't read anything
online about seo i mean it's kind of
important to read it to get the basics
but you have to think from the
perspective of a google engineer or a
google quality team
what's going to happen in five years
how would you write the algorithm if you
have a question in your head say
what would i do if i are the engineer
writing the search algorithm and we
always went by that there's also no
secret sauce it's just hard work
this is kind of the pitfall of most
seos i've met they want this payoff in
two weeks three months four months
they're not willing to invest two years
three years
to really win over the entire market
and again your most limited resources
founder time
if you don't extract yourself from the
business drivers
you're never going to get to the scale
you need to succeed so that's why it's
also important to know exactly what kind
of output you need on links and on
content to get to where you need to go
okay so
our first big investment
as a company
was spending every dime we had on hiring
a pr firm prowess pr
so this was five thousand dollars a
month and it was the first big
investment so what did we learn building
a reputation is really tough with
journalists they don't want to get
burned they have a job to do so their
job is to put out
informative news every day
they have a quota to hit
they have deadlines to meet and they're
flooded with emails so you can't burn
them and you have to speak to them in a
language that's conducive to get them
doing their job as quickly as possible
so talk to an ex-journalist they'll know
exactly what i'm talking about
uh this is anisha again our first
content hire so she
was put in charge of writing all the
content
i instantly realized she was much better
at writing than i was
and
this isn't
well i'll talk about that some other
time um but she hired and inspired great
content writers um who actually cared
about the topic at hand uh to really
push our
brand and content forward i repeat every
single piece of content is a touch point
for your brand your brand is just an
aggregate of everything everyone hears
and sees about your company so this was
super important
um so anisha was actually
studying arabic at brown
she wanted to go to syria and spend some
time there to learn arabic and
fortunately for nerd wallet the arab
spring happened and she couldn't go
so we asked her
to drop out of school and join us full
time and she was super instrumental
okay so 2012 we were starting to grow a
real user base
we had people focused on all the drivers
of the business 2013 was more of the
same
and
what got us there what got us through
all the hard times the slow roi at first
was realizing
hey what exactly do we need to do
quantitatively to win over time
and that forced the org structure
the hiring the business practices that
actually ensued
so uh okay so i'd say when you're small
you got to do whatever it takes to
figure out how to beat your small
competitors you got to give yourself
credit you're not going to get to where
you need to go immediately not on a run
rate basis
so give your credit that you're going to
iterate and get better over time it's
going to happen however
if what you need to do um if it's 500
great links a month or whatever it is
is so far-fetched that you know it'll
never happen don't even try
be realistic about what's completely
futile
and then when you're at scale
you're really screwing up if you're
growth hacking or thinking about tactics
there are people that are way smarter
than you i guarantee you um at these
things your job is to hire and inspire
them and put them to work in effective
ways
and so i'd say my biggest successes and
failures in the last four years
were all people's names
so 2012 to 2013 was probably the hardest
part of my uh entire career as an
entrepreneur
managing people is really tough
i had a lot of really poor preconceived
notions of what a good culture or
management situation looked like
based on my previous tenure as a hedge
fund analyst where people would throw
telephones at you and pay you a lot of
money so that's not really the right way
to inspire people
and then last thing i realized is that
people build companies
as an investor i had this totally warped
perception that business models and
business modes build companies
that may be true later later later on in
your company
but
it's very logical
your output as an entrepreneur is going
to be the quality and enthusiasm of
people working in parallel doing the
right things
okay so a few tips for first-time
managers because this really
hit close to home and i learned a lot of
lessons the really hard way
first of all it's not about rah-rah-rah
you got to be authentic people can
handle the truth
people want the truth people will freak
out and think you don't know what you're
doing if you don't tell them the truth
that they obviously know
so be authentic and don't be afraid to
communicate what's wrong with your
company vulnerabilities employees
everyone people are just really
perceptive
um
alignment is super tough so you gotta
totally over communicate on your mission
your expectations and give immediate
candid feedback in a really supportive
way
to people
a big mistake over time
my assumption going into management was
that
the issues were usually dna related i'd
be like oh this person just can't do
this that's almost never the case once
you have a really candid discussion
around what is going wrong
you realize they're not set up for
success or they're not doing the thing
that they're actually good at so that's
important
so
number three super critical especially
as you scale you are guaranteed to run
into tons of problems
misunderstandings people are going to
step on each other's toes you have to
confront these issues candidly and
quickly you want people to tell you
when they think your product direction
is wrong
you want people to tell you when they
think you're not leading the company
properly otherwise you're never going to
get there
and lastly learn about people it really
becomes more about understanding people
at this stage the business strategy is
super easy the people really hard
and so now we
we crossed 2.2 million users at the end
of last year
we're at nearly 200 employees
and at this stage uh
when we're about a hundred people
started thinking really hard well
where's this company ultimately going
and how can we be successful in two or
three years
so hired some great people um boscar
built the
data infrastructure and security teams
at linkedin dan ran biz ops which is
business operations and strategies at
linkedin
flow was the first recruiter at zynga
and ken ran communications at trulia
which was kind of interesting because
they had succeeded in the exact same way
we succeeded
and ken was there from pretty much the
beginning
and so a few summary points here so
first of all yeah understand
what channel do i need to dominate what
are the drivers behind that channel
what exact metrics do i have to hit
and even if i'm making seven cents per
visitor now understand what are the big
guys making what will that ultimately be
so that you will have faith that you
will get there eventually
tactics
tactics become
pretty commoditized pretty quickly
so it's about quick iteration
accurate diagnosis candid conversations
and you want to build your business
processes around the drivers of your
acquisition channel
and then hire great people i can't
emphasize this one enough if you don't
learn how to sell a vision you're not
going to attract great people and
companies are built by people working in
parallel
with differing talents than you so you
have to learn how to do that
uh yeah but thank you opening it up for
questions
thanks tim we have time for one or two
hey
great talking thanks
um so you're talking about seo
and you're saying not to look on google
for seo tips so i was wondering
how you would go about learning about
seo and the good strategies
yeah
so just on a really high level i mean if
you think about it from google's
perspective
their company succeeds
if they surface the best results
to
consumers that's how people ultimately
end up going back to google over and
over again over time
so if you think what about what that
means in the long term it means the
indicators of search quality are going
to change over the time they're going to
constantly improve
also google has chrome google has google
analytics google has all these other
indicators of search quality
that they may or may not claim that they
use but hell if i'm google i'm trying to
offer the best search results i'm going
to track everything that these different
sources of data give me
and so you ultimately need to figure out
how to build to meet that need to win
five years out rather than getting mired
in this like brutal competition in the
short run
so what about like resources like seomoz
i don't know if you know about that like
yeah i think i think moz is a great
resource so
when you especially when you're earlier
on um
i think it's more relevant in terms of
understanding what other people are
doing
but tactics commoditize quickly
and there's pretty much open
transparency across the board in terms
of what everyone's tactics are if you
use moz
thanks
thanks again for the talk um so you
talked about hiring some really great
people um at what point like how do you
manage that you know you're working with
some really great people
wouldn't you feel like at some point
they could just you know
kind of bend off and go do their own
thing like how do you make sure that
you're continuously inspiring them and
you know kind of holding the reins of
the company yeah so i i have every
expectation that great people will peel
off and go do their own thing
um so
i really think about you know finding
people at the right cross section in
their careers where this is the right
opportunity they're going to grow in the
right way and they're going to have
chances to do things that excite them
and that's really to me what a company
is it's just a collection of these
people i mean of course they're going to
go leave and do bigger and better things
afterwards great that's all the time we
have thank you okay thanks